I know how reject nation it's Greg Alba
here then it's John here
so we're gonna watch trailer for the
disaster artist official trailer number
two right now I am recovering from
pretty nasty cold and sick the past
couple days I still can't hear out of
this ear it is ringing really loud right
now and I don't know what to do about it
Tommy was one of my inspirations I think
he's one of the reasons that John and I
were able to put together a Greg saw
sketch it out
I'm not
[Music]
don't talk about 190 clients with
anybody you know of course shut up one
time try not fall asleep very body
am i hearing an accent oh no what would
you mean yeah I just turned 14 sounds
like a thing here
[Music]
[Music]
you are perfect
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the actual closer he directed this day
now that I didn't realize that he
directed those three trailers later John
yeah somehow I got so wrapped up the
idea that he was playing Tommy he's
directed a few films and this fight this
seems to be the one that he's that is
getting the most critical reception -
well in a way it's almost like he's
living the life by doing all these
different roles on a movie about a guy
who did all the different roles on his
own yeah for my recollection he's done
other biopic little projects here and
there
he loves to direct that's why I think he
went to NYU is to learn how to ride in
direct I don't really hear people praise
in the direction of it but I'm hearing
so many early praises that this is like
one of his or possibly his best
performance he's ever given this is our
eras Atwood in terms of what Tim Burton
and Johnny Depp did with Ed Wood yeah
James Franco has done pretty much by
himself it's ah that's a kind of movie
we don't get to see a lot you know these
aren't the figures that we usually turn
into biopic so I'm fascinated great
movie about terrible filmmaker borrowing
some of the style of the movie you know
T and make it in the first place
I hope this films a hit each trailer is
communicating a different type of theme
and tone the first trailer was just
straight-up hilarious we're all familiar
with the kind of banter rhythm and style
that you'd expect where to get the
Franco brothers in there and Seth Rogen
in there yeah which is just that scene
and the first trailer kind of leads with
like here's how we're recreating the
stuff you know yeah you know and the
second one hat is still on the more
humorous side with hints of a dramedy in
there and this one is like way more a24
a lot more character piece yeah yeah
yeah like oh you're probably gonna be
emotionally moved you're not really
laughing hysterically throughout this
trailer you could feel more of the drama
and the intensity of certain situations
happening and there will be the humor
that comes from the absurdity of it all
for my understanding these guys really
do love that
oh yeah there were some of the early
people who came out you know like some
of the early like famous people who
started just like coming to the
screenings cuz they dug it you know I
get the sense in like Jonah Hill and a
bunch of other people like I remember
reading articles being like this is a
phenomenon James Franco has such a hard
time daily the voice he wouldn't stay in
character because he was directing but
he would stay in the voice while he was
on set because he wanted he needed it to
sound natural and not sound like an
imitation I think that's the number one
thing I keep noticing whenever I see a
trailer James Franco is not doing an
impersonation when this is so easy to
fall into impersonation over again
someone like Tommy Weiser to get
cartoonian to get care about it and the
one yeah that's something that
consistently sort of impresses me about
the footage that we're seeing from this
movie is every time he speaks now I'm
like wow yeah it sounds like you really
learned this guy's voice like it's right
now and those weird little like ha ha ha
like those laughs he does he's making
them look at least from these clips very
natural hats off already for that I hope
this films the hit because getting
really great early praise I open may be
so funny if it got like some awards
consideration to it smell late in the
year it's coming out what irony if they
won awards for a movie that could never
possibly based on what are you excited
for the disaster artist what's your
favorite James Franco performance if
it's spider-man 3 whoa yeah well yeah
that breakfast montage don't forget that
I love this nice time Peter in the
coffee shop about you know about Mary
Jane not being into him and he has his
lazy eye I'm the same that's why you
know James Franco doesn't care all right
guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell you
could follow us on social media and
please go ahead and check out our
patreon become a patriotic today but
post a lot of fun stuff over there we'll
catch you guys later